first we turn to the harris biden
campaign as
the ever weak frail forgetful joe calls
it now today while biden spent most of
the day at his basement bunker
preparing for his big uh drive-up town
hall where he's not asked a single tough
question
his running mate actually hit the road
at a round table senator harris just
burst out laughing when discussing
children returning to school
i don't know why this is funny maybe you
can figure it out take a look
one of the biggest dilemmas for any of
us as a parent is what to do about
our kids in school k through 12 college
all of that and we all want them to go
back to school
right
um but safely
who's going to play her on saturday
night live i guess jim carrey is playing
biden
i don't know what's so funny kids
returning to school to get an education
that they really can't get most big
cities run by liberal democrats for
decades
allowing parents to get back to work i
don't see the funniness here maybe
you just don't understand what it's like
to be on lockdown under one roof with
kids unable to go to school
and parents unable to go to work and
democrats withholding funding
and playing politics with relief money
maybe you can relate
maybe you're just a fake out of touch
far left swamp politician who will do
and say anything for power
after all while senator harris supported
restrictive lockdowns for most americans
we the people
she simultaneously applauded the writing
across the country and the deep funding
of the lapd
great move mayor garcetti 150 million
there
yeah we just had attempted assassination
of two
uh police officers out in los angeles
and compton in fact she even promoted
that bail fund
used to get riders out of jail no one's
asked her that question
that's the very same fun that kamala
harris promoted
bailed out a woman accused of shooting
at police an alleged murderer
a twice convicted rapist and a 36 year
old man accused of raping an
eight-year-old little girl
that is the bail fund that kamala harris
openly supported supported
and promoted nobody in the mob has
bothered to ask yet
that's the fun the biden campaign
staffers personally donated to
pretty sickening but will anyone in the
mob in the media
state-run tv will they ever ask joe or
kamala a single question about any of
these things
it didn't come up once tonight that from
the time
president trump put the travel ban in
effect and the first quarantine in 50
years
not once not a single time did they ever
ask why were you calling it
xenophobia hysterical xenophobia and
fear mongering
through the almost the end of march uh
why were you hiding in your basement
what did you do joe um how is it that
um you don't know vaccines on the
horizon
anyway on tuesday joe got off his
private jet in florida
answered as usual zero questions
appeared to
wave at a crowd there's nobody there
it's like a cornfield or something i
don't wave into a field
highfield hello it's joe today joe biden
holding this virtual event from the
comfort of his own home
where as per usual joe biden became
incredibly confused take a look
and so joe uh hi
this is about the only few minutes i'll
see you today
[Laughter]
so would you like to say a couple words
am i supposed to speak now or as karen's
supposed to speak i don't know i don't
want to get in trouble here
well it's me okay well jill it's great
to see you at a distance
move up we'll we'll
joe biden wants to be the president of
the united states the hardest job in the
world can't even get through a
zoom call from his sofa in his own
basement bunker without looking like a
total [ __ ]
and joe biden again tonight listed
everything he would do if
he was elected president everything that
he'd do on covert 19. the only problem
is
every single thing he listed donald
trump did a long time ago
and by the way look at this headline in
today's usa today
fisa reports potential of covet 19
candidate vaccine after expanding
the final stage 3 uh trial to 44
000 people by the way these final stage
human trials started in july guess what
we're now seeing significant results
what they're learning and telling us the
vaccine's optimal dose has been
discovered to create
antibodies and that meaning they're
fully successfully formed
with no deaths and minimal side effects
like maybe a headache or minor muscle
pain
by the way read your tylenol bottle
about the risk there
joe biden has been hiding in his
basement during the covid
sleep more concerned about how china
would view the united states for putting
the travel ban in place and the first
quarantine in 50 years
why didn't he make those decisions and
by the way
i'd like to ask at his town hall tonight
anderson cooper
you like to claim you're a super
journalist right you do the job you're
fair and balanced
he said that the ban was hysterical
xenophobia and fear mongering from
the time we implemented it to the end of
march
why didn't you ask him why he said that
because that one decision
saved hundreds of thousands of americans
from contracting the virus and likely
dying
you might want to have asked him those
questions